what do we think about what's going on
in the border also i didn't know that we
bordered haiti did you guys know that
i had no clue i thought he was an island
i don't know where taiwan is but you
don't know where it is well i thought
haiti was an island i thought haiti
shared an island with dominican republic
no it's right on the southern border i
guess it is mexico and then haiti right
there and why what was taking them for
so long why weren't they coming in
before i think they were going the wrong
way they went south and they were like
oh [ __ ] oh my goodness man yeah oh my
goodness no explain explain that to me
where'd they come through so after the
earthquake in haiti a lot of them fled
to like south america yeah and then they
were given like political asylum in like
parts like argentina and like southern
south america and they lived there for a
while and then times changed and those
countries had like more desperate
financial situations so they started
like kind of kicking them out they
removed like their political asylum
status gave them like tourist status and
so then they kind of were just like
refugees again and had to like kind of
move their way
basically through like the southern like
continent to then get to
del rio
and now they're there and now by the
administration's like all right we're
going to try to deport them but like
they can apply for political asylum but
they have to either they have to get the
application they have to get it approved
through like their filing system then
they either approve it or deny it if
they deny it then they get flown back to
haiti and if they get approved then
they're able to live here as well who
flies them back
delta
we pay for that i mean the government
yeah man got here
boy that's crazy
you got to pay the flying bag
how else did they get them back
that's not on us
well it is because they're here they got
here yeah and now we want them to not be
here because they don't have to live
assignments so you got to pay to fly
them home whoa
whoa we probably send the bill to haiti
be like yo that's what you owe us
that's cool
we're probably waiting a while to get
paid back control your peoples yeah they
said put on our tab yeah yeah that's
right they're probably super debt right
now yeah no but that is kind of crazy we
pay so like anybody can come here and
then you just get a first class ticket
home i don't know his first class i mean
i don't even get a first-class ticket
but you get to fly like that's probably
a lot of their first time even on a
plane yeah maybe so if you want to just
fly somewhere in your life might as well
just try to get into america like
i mean can you just can i sneak into
america and be like no i'm actually from
uh bali
i'm here for refugee status but i'm
really from bali and they're like all
right well sorry you gotta go to bali
shucks and then you send me to bali
we should try that yeah
that's ridiculous
i mean how annoyed would you be if you
got a connecting flight though say what
i can't even get to board a direct guy
come on fam really gonna put me through
frankfurt and i i would rather be like i
might sneak out
you want me to sneak out in frankfurt
huh
huh you want me to do that [ __ ] yeah
it's about germany about to get a little
more polynesian
i want to direct them real talk you
better send me direct or i'm i'm
escaping yeah i'm a skate you know i
escaped
i'm out here escaping bro i'm a scape
artist
if you're deported on the plane you're
probably so happy that you're probably
like having a great time getting drinks
and [ __ ] you won yeah you [ __ ] double
biscoff cookies who cares yeah he's
wrong
you're not going to eat a lot in your
homeland just stuff it up that's what i
mean oh did we talk about that karen
that i sat in there oh my god was that
before we got no we have to i think she
was getting deported that's what she was
100 we have to talk about absolutely
murdering somebody on a plane
um okay so
but just in conclusion with the haiti
thing i don't think that's fair that we
fly them back what i do think is fair is
if you show up to our borders because we
do have a rule where we accept refugees
right we want we are whether they give
us your hunger give us your poor
whatever that's part of like the
credence of america so i like the idea
that you could come and you could apply
for that and then we see if you actually
are a refugee or not you know because
you could just be a [ __ ] terrorist
and then say you're a refugee and then
ah welcome to del rio and then [ __ ] i
don't know blow up some airport or some
[ __ ] who knows but also if they're
terrorists you could just fly in and
just be like yeah i'm here for two weeks
and then do some terrorist stuff
well we also vet you wherever you're
flying in from it's not like anybody can
just get in you go through customs and
they're like you're good oh you're white
[Laughter]
they asked some [ __ ] questions bro
you speak the english perfectly but if
you were there like
you know like they're gonna have
right like it's gonna be a little harder
if you just visit iraq once in your life
when you go to the airport it's a
problem really four hours early you have
to be
no yes go through your whole luggage
everything
that's factual i saw this [ __ ] happen to
a guy in the airport took every piece of
his luggage off the [ __ ] belt
put him in a room they were there for
five hours
damn and what did he end up doing say
what what did he end up doing they
killed him
they killed him at the airport yeah
and and why why'd they do because
because they're mad or he was muslim and
we haven't talked about them yet on this
podcast so yeah you killed him no you
did you said something about uh
rocks i freaked out
so they didn't kill him actually no i
think eventually they let him in canada
and you also talk about how
bala is the uh
sour complainer oh yes i did sure i
didn't know that is anything i think
it's more of a pakistani insole yeah
true true that's not much of a joke
that's just really
oh yeah they still let you fly in israel
you get a second power no they don't
they don't they don't stab your
passports which would they want your
tourism and your visit but the stamp
causes problem when you visit other arab
countries so now they just stamp a piece
of paper and put in your passport so you
don't even need to get the second
passport you just get that little little
paper
you don't have that lit stamp i tell
them i don't need that paper stamp my
password we had a hard time going to
russia stamping oh that's right because
we were smuggling goods yeah yeah they
know we were spies oh that's right but
they also don't we want to pay for the
flight back just because it probably
costs more to keep them in
town oh i don't think we do more damage
this should be the thing this is what
you're gonna this should be the changes
it should be the rules right this should
be the rules and maybe i sound like your
liberal kodak black you don't want cold
white black and in america son
i love haitians that's what i'm saying
we got to keep kodak black in town
these people are not haitian
they're probably dominican blind
they're probably dominican and they're
lying
i think they're dominican they're lying
about it they're doing a french accent
racist of course you think they're doing
like first of all it's not french
sorry okay it is not [ __ ] french okay
what do they speak what is the language
creole and you think they're doing a
creole accent these dominicans yes they
are they are doing it and that would be
raises to them to do part pardon that
would be raises if they were to be it
would be racist so we are this is how we
treat raise people no
uh and what i'm saying immigration in
general
it should be yo if you just pull up to
the border like on some refugee [ __ ]
yeah
be ready to wait a couple days fam
you better have a hotel hooked up well i
think that's what they do they show up
and they plan to get caught and then as
soon as they get caught ain't no caught
that's the whole point is they show up
and get caught on purpose nah
that's why the wall makes sense if it
actually stops people if it doesn't stop
people that's fine but if you actually
have a wall right what it will do is
funnel people let's say there is an
effective wall i'm not saying we can't
do that but let's say there is an
effective wall right
effective wall where people can't get in
it will funnel people to the the booths
or like the reception centers where they
actually have to apply for refugee
status so they're not trying to get
caught they're literally just going yo
i'm here i'm a refugee police we look at
your paperwork you go back stay on the
[ __ ] street or stay in a hotel or
stay at a uh some sort of like uh
shelter or whatever while we look at
this thing ideally you're telling the
truth you are a refugee we bring you in
we give you the best life that you could
possibly have here right i think that
that is a very fair way to go through it
uh because there are people who are not
refugees and they might be doing it
because they want a better life but
that's not fair to the people that are
also want a better life from other parts
of the world that can't just walk across
the border yeah but they're waiting
years
in a visa application process when they
go to the shelters and [ __ ] like that
you're paying for that no the shelters
outside of america
you so you think no mexico just has a
bunch of shelters just that they're
paying for
please believe
if they're just people wandering the
streets and it bothers mexico enough
they'll either protect their borders so
it doesn't happen there or they'll build
some shelters
so i'm saying like it's not inconvenient
for them so why would they do anything
because they know the second they get
here they're like okay we're out of here
so now we flying people all the [ __ ]
there's no cost for coming to america
right there's no cost at all and i'm all
for people coming to america i'm only
here because my mom came to america like
let's bring more people in the idea that
like the [ __ ] is packed is a lie like
new people i'm telling you but we went
to omaha dog like there's no there's
room b there's so much there's room
and it's not like these people are being
picky it's not like haitians are coming
in like i'm only living in miami sorry
you know what i mean like everywhere i
go i see mexicans
you know what i mean so it's not like
they're just chilling in [ __ ] san
diego so you can pop down tijuana
whenever they want yeah like where's the
opportunity where can i change my life i
want people to have the opportunity to
change their [ __ ] lives but i also
think there should be some sort of
system to make sure that we do this and
wouldn't you want to be able to document
all the people that are coming in yeah
not only for us but for them but
apparently a lot of them don't want to
be documented so they're like throwing
away their papers throwing away all like
their ids and [ __ ] because they don't
want the government to know who they are
well once the government knows who they
are maybe they won't let them in exactly
and that's the unfortunate thing because
now they're [ __ ] up for the people
who would love the government to know
who they are the people who've been here
for [ __ ] years and they're like man i
just want to be a [ __ ] citizen i want
to pay taxes i want to continue raising
my family and it's just like please i
can i tell you can i tell you i want to
have my life here
i don't know
i love the idea of like making
immigration
i don't want oh i don't want open
borders i don't think there is a country
if you have open borders borders define
the country but i love the idea of a
much more efficient process and if that
takes building some sort of [ __ ]
protective structure to funnel people
into one area so we could just make sure
that you get these people documented and
you get them a safe place to go like
what about these [ __ ] women across
the border they have no [ __ ] place to
go and they get scooped up by these
these uh sex trafficking sex trafficking
things like the coyotes they have to pay
them back so that they have to they have
to do these [ __ ] up jobs and they're
taking all the money to do the [ __ ] up
jobs yeah it's like these people still
get punished no matter what so what kind
of structure you want you want like a
wall like a
american ninja warrior course i would
like i would like that yeah i i want
something that they cannot
i want some they cannot get past so like
uh
mexicans let's say abs
yeah they have to have apps they have to
have a six-pack abs okay and then they
can get into america all right i mean
that would stop all immigration from
mexico i've never seen
mexicans with a six-pack act there's
gotta be some canelo's the only one and
he's gotta be irish i mean he's the
reddest mexican i've ever seen in my
entire chicharrito he's probably gotta
get six back i don't think so they don't
do it why not four
only four stops at four they didn't add
the two one they're shorter they dubside
uh-huh they're dove side mexican
he's the mexicans of africa
moroccans are known as the mexicans of
ours
[Laughter]
but isn't that a reasonable approach to
immigration
uh
maybe i don't really know enough about
him great job
but like we have to acknowledge just the
idea that like the door is open yeah it
seems great i mean it seems a little
ridiculous on the one hand it's like i
feel bad as these people are leaving
they got nothing living under a bridge
for two weeks something like i don't
want to be living under a bridge but at
the same time it's like i don't know
what you do yeah
i mean also if it's flying i'm home and
it's like how much does it take to fly
home just put them on spirit airlines
and then what happens they come right
back it's like i just think they're
losing motion is like it's too
optimistic because i don't think you
know mexico is building [ __ ] you think
they're just boomerang
you think they send them home and they
fly right back can i say one thing
home is horrible right they're being
abused right
mm-hmm okay
they come to us for help
another place to stay
we send them back home they're trying to
leave they want to spend a night in put
us in jail
exactly put us in the jail plea anything
anything some murder's gonna happen so
we should put them in jail we have to
put them in america jail
okay
put them in america jail america is a
jail absolutely build a wall build four
walls who knows build four walls
no
but just to wrap it up because i was
talking about your thing in all
seriousness it does seem kind of
ridiculous that there's just this this
open door
and we all turn a blind eye because the
people that are on the coast don't have
to deal with this at all and we go oh
you're racist if you have any issue with
it yeah even though we know absolutely
nothing and we don't know how it's not
negatively affecting those communities
but like if you live in that community
you see all these people coming in like
it's tough i think like if you actually
have some compassion emotionally you're
like [ __ ] i want to help these people
yeah we're just gonna ignore this it's
happening and then you gotta listen to
some [ __ ] [ __ ] in new york or la go
oh this isn't the american way to do it
oh is it not
donate some money
let's build a shelter where's your
[ __ ] money yeah where's your money
hollywood
you got a problem with the cages build
some [ __ ]
like hello let's do it put your money
where your [ __ ] mouth is
yeah i mean i do agree with people that
have nothing to like that it doesn't
affect their lives at all probably have
like the worst takes in general yeah i
mean it's like the rich kids are like no
people are illegal and say all right
do something about it yeah what would
you like to do are no people illegal
help them all yeah you hire every single
one
or just go down there look what's going
on
what if they just make the citizenship
process super easy or like the green
card process like yo if you come through
green card only only uh if it doesn't
affect the other people that are trying
to go through the legal process at all
because i think that's kind of unfair
because there are people i'm sure
refugees from all around the world that
are like waiting for their opportunity
to come here so they can do their dream
job they can escape
probably after afghans they're trying to
get over afghans like there's so many
people i'm sure they're trying to come
in every country there's like a green
card lottery and they're actually not
leaving their countries until they have
some access and they have a touch point
already in the u.s if this is better for
them to just leave their country fly to
[ __ ] mexico and then walk over
where it's where
what's it called
disincentivizing or de-incentivizing the
legal process
in this way
right because if it takes two years that
way but if you just walk across the
border citizenship why the [ __ ] am i
doing paperwork you know i hate
paperwork
or is it just prioritizing the people
that are the most desperate how do you
define that if you're willing to just
fly to mexico and then cross like this
well maybe you're a woman in afghanistan
you can't do that
right you know what i'm saying like
there's desperation everywhere and
there's different types of desperation
you know so there's no question these
people are desperate they're no question
that they're uprooting their entire
lives and their families yeah i mean
it's [ __ ] tragic it's horrible you
know but to act like we can't improve
the system i think is incredibly naive
and i i really think it's people just
ignoring a problem because they don't
want to deal with it
and they don't have to deal with it
because they're not close to it at all
yeah like it's an issue we should do
something about it and we should stop
[ __ ] politicizing it like every
[ __ ] thing we do in america same
thing with the masks and [ __ ] it's just
like
if the wall the wall could be a
monumental waste of money and it
couldn't stop anything and then it's
stupid but if the wall actually worked
and that and the wall outed us allowed
us to have
like these centers where these people
could go to and actually properly get
vetted and maybe even places to stay
while they're being vetted et cetera
that are not [ __ ] cages like
and the the wall provided that security
because now you didn't need people
detailing the border constantly the
border existed
wouldn't you sleep a little bit better
if you knew like these people that are
leaving these incredibly tough
situations at least come here and they
have a fair chance and the ones that
should be able to seek uh refuge can
yeah i think the solution is probably
like politically nuanced and but it just
feels like either side like his other
yeah but either through
points it's just like harping on like
get illegals out of here like get them
like we got to protect america strong
borders like get these [ __ ] out
of here or it's like no one's illegal
like everyone should be welcome here
everyone should be allowed in blah blah
blah bro i mean it's also money it's
money they don't want to
spend the money to build shelters to
spend they're about to spend 3.5
trillion dollars to rebuild all the
roads and the highways it's just
building it's like you're going to hire
some people they're going to make it
that actually pay for it bro like come
on that's nice
but when he was saying that and mexico
was like [ __ ] out of here and then
nothing happened
we don't want to pay for it they don't
want to pay for it yeah like he
negotiated like andrew on that one
he's like yo i'm a good guy just don't
with me it's the same it's the same now
we don't want to pay for it and mexico
doesn't want to do anything and so
that's why they're just going to be
stalled there in [ __ ] limbo yeah and
it's just a shame that governments are
letting people struggle like that yeah
yeah like the fix is throwing a bunch of
money at it and no one wants to do that
that's the only thing that's gonna throw
money in this right way otherwise no i
mean like like you said build a bunch of
shelters but that's also shelters that's
running water that's food staff that's
staff that's like that's a lot of money
yeah yep yep it is unfortunate
it is unfortunate or you just the
solution now it seems like with body
administration is like pay money to send
them back home
boom and it's like we're spending money
cheaper i don't know if it's cheaper
because you need a house it's not like
they're going right from there to the
[ __ ] airport i mean they're living
under a bridge right now yeah they go
right from there del rio like there's
ten thousand if you look at the pictures
it's unreal there's ten it looks like
[ __ ] edc bro there's ten thousand the
haitian people just all underneath this
giant bridge like sprawling like this
whole section of del rio it's crazy
that's why it's cheaper to fly them home
so they're gonna fly home 10 000 people
yeah from del rio mexico yeah where
they're bringing them into america and
then flying them home or no they're in
del rio texas i think it's like they're
in texas there is the most southern part
of texas yeah so they're already in yeah
wow and why why aren't they going to
miami you don't see the guys on horses
[ __ ] whipping them i thought that
they were doing that as they were trying
to cross over i mean yeah i guess they
were yeah like a bunch of i mean you
have like five guys on horseback and
thousands of people in a caravan just
like running up oh yeah yay
but yeah and i think the thing is like
they want to give themselves up and so
they're rather like we'll author stay
here or we'll go back to haiti either
way it's better than being stuck in
mexico or wherever we are
[ __ ] hell man
we got to have some sort system i
the idea that like
we i think you can have strong borders
and you can also protect america but i
also think you protect america by
maybe i'm biased because i'm the son of
an immigrant but like i think you
protect america by continuing
immigration immigration is how we built
this country you know and like getting
the people who are super hungry for the
american experience in american dream is
how we continue to have prosperity right
like i don't know i
i think it's it's a huge advantage that
people want to play here it's like it's
like the nba you know what i mean like
you want to play everybody wants to play
like luca doncic is like i want out of
my country so i could hoop in the best
place in the whole [ __ ] world and i
understand that these people are
refugees and they're leaving incredibly
difficult circumstances but like
in my experience those people are ready
to grind the hardest they're willing to
work the hardest because it's like i
don't want to go back to that yeah i
need to make and then you're saying
when people who come from no opportunity
see a little bit of opportunity they're
not complacent they're like hold on the
harder i work the more money i make yeah
the more opportunity i get the more i
get to provide like i i don't know i
like that energy i like that mentality
and i like that [ __ ] grind getting
paid american dollars
i can live off half this and half back
to haiti but the problem is but legally
but legally and have a proper that's the
thing you can't do it legally when it's
that many people trying to come at the
same time and you don't have enough
people to process their information yeah
and so your decisions have to be made
and that's where it [ __ ] says you
give yourself up go through the legal
way and then you have to go through all
this bureaucracy and you might get
kicked out or you just [ __ ] roll the
dice say yo i'm [ __ ] i'm going to
live illegally i can try to get married
try to like finesse it try to work it
out maybe someone grants me like
a visa through work and i'm just going
to bet on myself and worst case scenario
i'll get deported later i completely get
why they do it there's no question but i
do think it's
up to us to devise a much better system
than one we have now and be great if
politicians would remove themselves from
it ultimately i understand that they
have to make the decisions and that's
what democracy is but it'd be nice if
the experts actually sat down crunched
the numbers and found out how the [ __ ]
to properly handle this situation with
the least amount of
uh human casualty i don't mean that in
terms of death but like
yeah suffering and distress yeah i think
there's got to be a better way yeah i
just don't know what it is
you